Europe declares null and void
all the loans that have been given in Spain.
How about taking a look at the news?
All those loans that they have been giving
both banks and smaller financial institutions,
loans of €30,
loans of €30,000
or even those payments
that he has been purchasing the appliance,
1 TV,
1 computer,
1 piece of furniture and has been paying in installments.
All this Europe is declaring null and void.
Next question,
what will you ask yourselves,
And why does it declare this loan null and void?
It declares it null and void
if they have not done before granting you the loan
of study
of the possibility that you may have to return that money.
1 financial study of the individual
the one they entrust to the one who gets that money.
What is the reality
that almost never do.
Therefore,
almost all loans are null and void.
And now comes the part that interests you the most,
what does it mean that 1 loan is null and void?
Well,
they have to return everything you have paid for,
interest on expenses and commissions.
And Europe says no
only loans being paid now,
loans that were already repaid years ago.
You may also claim
and get back everything you paid for,
interest on expenses and commissions
of all kinds.
So we are talking from loans
personal experiences that can be given to you by
or the issuing bank
a uh,
loans
small that can give live from €50 to 100 from €300
or deferred payments to purchase 1 appliance from you,
1 refrigerator or 1 computer
or 1 sofa.
All these are loans.
Even your car financing
is also 1 loan and all that can be null and void.
Europe says so
because as I tell you,
have not done solvency analysis
of the people to whom the loan is given.
Loan,
almost never do so.
Here is 1 example,
you have bought um,
1 computer
or 1 fridge or whatever.
For we are going to put €500,
you pay month by month,
pay, pay,
pay,
pay and at the end in the last,
in the last installment,
you start adding and you see that you have paid €1 100.
Well,
what can you do now?
Do it now? Well,
if you claim
will have to return that difference to you,
will have to return €600,
you were given 500,
you have paid 1,100.
The €600 difference
which are interests,
are expenses,
they are commissions,
all kinds of which have been charged to you.
that now has to be returned to you.
And how do I do it?
Sergio,
How do I do it?
I'm already nervous,
huh?
Don't worry,
I'll help you
if you take 1 look at the profile link,
there you will see my phone,
my email and at no cost to you.
I repeat,
at no cost to you.
I help you without any problem.
And why would you say how it can be free of charge?
Because it does not charge you,
It charges them,
the banks